[Music]
what month did you say your birthday was
in June
it's like June 18th yeah okay what is
going on what is this video about
suppose you were born in September that
would mean your birthday would come just
after the cutoff date for most schools
in the United States so if you're 15 on
September 1st you would play for the 15
year old team even if you were turning
16 on the second studies have shown that
this age gap can give you an advantage
because on average you're bigger and
stronger than the younger competition
this is called the relative age effect
does being born in September make you
better at sports I'm here at BuzzFeed to
find out Patrick was bad at sports kind
of thing kinda I was kind of bad well I
first broke my nose while doing
gymnastics and then I broke it again
because the basketball like hit me in
the face and gym classes I thought oh
you know what I certainly wasn't the
worst I wasn't interested in being the
best if let's say that say there's 30
kids I probably came up 7th yeah it's
usually pretty pretty high up on the
skill level I don't want to sit here me
like I was the best at sports but I kind
of was in high school I was probably
like a four or five in elementary school
I was probably at like a two or three
but my heart level was like a 10 like I
believed I could do anything I wanted I
was the team captain of my high school
tennis team I was the team captain of my
squash team I made varsity of football
and I played oh I played rugby in
college for a while too I sent out a
survey to BuzzFeed employees to see
what's the highest sports team they were
played for according to our study most
people quit after high school but we
actually found that there's three people
here that played professional sports and
two out of those three people were born
in October and November so maybe your
birthday does have an effect but we
don't know for sure
[Music]